good morning Hank it's Tuesday so on
Friday rosianna and I left the magic and
awesome of nerdcon stories to head up to
Princeton Minnesota where I raced cars
on a dirt track against best-selling
author and all-around awesome person
Maggie Steve otter so I can IndyCar
driver I know once told me that in
racing the only thing more dangerous
than being too aggressive is being too
cautious which is an observation that I
think applies to more than just racing
and while I'm certainly an uncommon ly
anxious person I don't think of myself
as an overly cautious one so I was
feeling kind of excited as we arrived at
the Princeton Speedway I mean at no
point did I actually think I could win
the race but I did think I could like
finish it without being pulled out of a
burning vehicle which as it turned out
was overly optimistic took my first ever
ride in a four-wheeler to my race car
which belonged to a 17 year old hence
its number my coach for the evening was
his dad Alan and special shout-out to
Alan's kids my pit crew ten-year-old
Alison and eight-year-old Erin my first
lesson was getting in and out of the car
which as you can see is ridiculously
difficult Hank I need to linger on this
shot for a moment because I want you to
understand how hard it is to get out of
these cars even when they are not on
fire also I want you to notice my
excellent eleanor and park t-shirt which
I got at dftba.com so Alan's an
experienced racecar driver and an
excellent coach I want to dump out of
the throttle he explained to me at least
a dozen times that coming out of the
corner I would give an urge to
overcorrect the steering and or let off
the throttle and that getting into that
urge would be a significant mistake and
I was able to remember that advice for
like five and a half laps of actual
racing put on my smoking hot fire suit
my helmet a pair of gloves and then
Maggie showed up with her awesome car
and it's awesome license plate and then
after an impossibly beautiful sunset
came to Princeton I belted myself in for
our first of three scheduled races
Maggie jumped out to a lead and she was
faster than me and also a much better
driver but my car turned really well in
the dirt and its power was exciting and
intoxicating and I was just trying to
keep up with her but then I thought you
know maybe I could drive alongside of
her and really make a race out of this
and then on the fifth lap coming out of
turn four I felt an urge to correct the
steering and
yeah the speedway staff got to me very
quickly and although I could feel the
heat of the fire in my back and legs
they kept me calm and pulled me out and
I was fine but I'm not gonna lie it was
terrifying but then they fixed the
problem with the car and for some reason
I decided to get back in it in fact I
won the second heat more precisely Maggi
let me win and I got a trophy and
everything and then we raced for a third
time and Maggi dominated me so
thoroughly that the regular Pro drivers
of the Speedway asked to take her on and
she beat them as well so Maggi won the
race but I caught fire and didn't get
hurt which felt very much like you know
some kind of winning and late that night
as I tried to sleep I kept playing the
race back in my mind me doing precisely
the thing I'd been told not to the heat
of the flames against my back my panic
hands as I tried to unbuckle the belts
the smokey relief of being pulled from
the car there are of course smart risks
the proper line to run through life is
somewhere between extreme caution and
extreme aggression but this wasn't one
of them
that's that Hank I have to confess that
I am proud to have lost to Maggie but
not to myself but in the end I think I'm
going to use this occasion to announce
my retirement from race car driving I'm
headed back to the grandstands where I
belong
Hank I'll see you on Friday